the fda has added these four brands of
hand sanitizer to a list of more than
75 that have been recalled some have
been sold at major nationwide stores
including walmart and target the
recalled brands contain
methanol a chemical used to create fuel
and antifreeze
it can make you sick if absorbed through
the skin nausea
vomiting headache maybe pins and needles
funny feeling
but the real classic symptom is
blindness
or vision disturbance at least two
people in arizona had to call poison
control recently
after using a recalled brand these
people admit to using it about
10 to 15 times a day two three four
days in a row and then on that fourth or
fifth day
they started to experience some vision
impairment in both cases vision returned
after the patient stopped using the hand
sanitizer
health experts say methanol can be
present in sanitizers when they're not
properly manufactured
and methanol won't be listed on the
label we really have to buy
hand sanitizer from a reputable source
or a reputable manufacturer
and if you're still unsure about hand
sanitizer
experts say you already have a great
solution at home
soap and water are extremely effective
at preventing the virus from spreading
many of the recalled hand sanitizers
come from outside of the country
and the fda has issued a warning to one
company in mexico
and place their products on a do not
import list michael george cbs news new
york